جلس على مقعده داخل مجلس الشيوخ اول مره
عام
1973 ولم يبرحه الا في عام 2008 عندما
انتقل الى البيت الابيض نائبا للرئيس
الاسبق باراك اوباما
اراد ان يسجل موقفا سريعا يظهره كشخصيه
الوطنيه
مناصب قياديه شغلها داخل الكونجرس لعل
ابرزها رئاسه اللجنه القضائيه لمده 17
عاما ولا يزال قانون يعرف بجرائم بيدن
يطارده حتى يومنا هذا حيث كان من كبار
المدافعين عن قانون الجرائم الفيدراليه
عام 1994
موبايل برز في لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه لعب
دورا في السياسه الخارجيه لمده 11 عاما
وكثيرا ما يتباهى بانجازاته في الخارج حتى
انه قدم قائمه الى واشنطن بوست بعد
اختياره نائبا لاوباما تظهر لقاءاته مع
150 زعيما من حوالي 60 دوله ومنظمه دوليه
ما جعل نقادا يصفون الامر بالمبالغه
مقللين من فتنه في السياسه الخارجيه
سياسته داخل الكونغرس كثيرا مع وصفت
بالازدواجيه بينما كان يدعم الجهود
الانسانيه في الخارج كان يدفع ايضا باتجاه
العمليات العسكريه في التسعينات تدخل
العسكري الامريكي في البلقاء
سالم
في تحرير الكويت عام 1991
هنا من بين من صوتوا لصالح غزو افغانستان
عام 2001 وسوط ايضا لصالح الحرب العراق في
عام 2002
35 عاما قضاها بيض بين اروقه الكونجرس
[موسيقى]
قابله 10 اعوام مجموع خبرته في البيت
الابيض لعل خبرته في المجال التشريعي
جعلته يقدر الان مدى تاثير التجديد النصفي
على منصبه فهو يدركه انها بمثابه استفتاء
شعبي على فتره
[تصفيق]